[Music]
[Applause]
for example I was watching that show The
Biggest Loser yeah I was checking out
that show and then I hit the info button
and this is what it said it said you
after the holidays
oh my god then I was watching America's
Most Wanted watching that show and I hit
the info button and it said for the
first time tonight's episode is Florida
free Celebrity Apprentice
I was watching Celebrity Apprentice yeah
and then I hit the info button it said
check out the cast of Celebrity Rehab a
year early yeah yeah I am
Diane what it's ion's earring okay
thanks a lot done that saved the show 19
19 Kids and Counting I was watching that
show yeah I'm gonna hit the input button
it said ever think about your parents
doing it these kids are forced to every
day 60 minutes I was watching 60 minutes
yeah and then I hit the info button and
said pretend you're skyping with your
late grandparents
NCIS New Orleans NCIS New Orleans and I
hit the info button and said just like
the other NCS shows but some of these
corpses ate gumbo I'm gonna leak it out
there
Chicago Fire as watching Chicago Fire I
hit the info button and it said dirt
makes the case for new hoses huh just
made that up no idea if there's a Dirk
in this American Country Music Awards
yeah watching that hit the info button
people who don't believe in evolution
singing and finally I was watching naked
and afraid
naked and afraid hit the info button
original title Conan's wedding night
[Applause]
you
you